very interesting
but that's that's humans you know like
everyone like if we saw
if you heard shouting outside
big loud chat were you gonna go look
outside yeah no it's true but like and
no disrespect because i think she's
incredibly talented but no matter how
many guys want lizzo she's just not my
type
do you know what i mean
lizzie was a lot of guys
personally someone out there maybe i
don't know no i'm just saying in general
like if you look at the attractiveness
scale yeah she's not really high on the
socially commercially attractiveness
scale is she it's unfortunate i think
she has a pretty face i think if she
lost weight she'd be pretty cute
actually yeah but if she lost weight
that would just
go against everything that she is yeah i
feel sorry for her she because she's
[Music]
and then she lost that weight and she
got so much hate yeah well i don't know
why as like why do we lie to women we do
not look better fatter like what i don't
understand that's body shaming it's not
it's just it's just
i wouldn't i'm not counseling i'm sorry
if i gained 100 pounds i would not be
cute like
why is that that's not crazy
why do you why do you but women say that
i said this though why do you because
there's nobody positivity for men no
look what happened to 50 cent the other
day 80 percent yeah what happened to
rick ross over there right now 50 came
out at the halftime super bowl
doing his uh
uh song yeah and he had put on weight he
put the same vest on that he had back in
the day and he looked people slaughtered
him yeah yeah yeah if that was a woman
well 80 of consumer buying decisions are
made by women and women so we're always
selling to women yeah
and they get their own dreams
maybe that's why they always lie to you
yeah yeah of course they get so dreams
and the thing is like i said women tell
each other lies as well like they'll
tell your girlfriend oh you look great
in that dress knowing that she looks
like a fat whale
well we're more agreeable we're more
agreeable
yeah that's why yeah
even even sometimes when i'm running
this show it's really hard for me to
tell people to shut the f up when they
keep talking like you guys it's funny
when it's only girls that do it right
like it's
like when i have got a group of guys in
here it's like very it's very like
it's very bad
so girls are like screaming
you were there everyone kept cutting
each other off
that's not i'm like agreeable so it's
nice but the thing is if you're around
women like that right
what it is it's very interesting though
that when you're around women like that
and they're just screaming and doing all
that
if you don't get in
yeah and just [ __ ] discipline the
[ __ ] team yeah then they're just
gonna think whatever i will keep going
but then when you try to do that they
get offended yeah yeah he's talking to
me what are you doing
listen just shut up
that happened to me not the show you
were at but a different show i did like
i had a girl text me and like because i
told her to like shut up basically
she was mad yeah
yeah it's like what did you say when she
touched you i mean i just said um i
don't know i i just said i didn't mean
it like that like it was just you kept
talking
but then would you say that that's
because you are more
you are less quote-unquote
female than them
do you think that is i think you're more
aware
gosh i mean i'm like
like saying i'm less female i'm sorry
[Applause]
but that's why i like that
i'm very logical i get it from my dad
like my dad's very logical so that's
that's kind of why i like this stuff
because i really like numbers and i've
always researched random things since i
was like a kid
so and i grew up between two boys so
maybe that's why right like in the
packing order i was right okay guys i
don't know because so you know sometimes
i feel like
it sounds like
bad and quite misogynistic but sometimes
like i said on the podcast when all the
girls were there
it's just like you feel like
you guys need to be disciplined like
children sometimes it's not like no yeah
like just you and it's like oh that's
misogynistic is that no sometimes when
women get no it's and it's hard because
it's not it's it doesn't come naturally
to me it does not oh that's not my
personality i was like
you need someone to play bad cop for you
that's why
i do
like once they get going it's just like
oh my god they're just gas snitch
they're all on the gas each other oh my
god and it just gets like
what the [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
it's like calm down
but the thing is if you say that it's
that oh you're a misogynist oh oh you're
trying to control me all this kind of
stuff it's like no but we can actually
see that though it's so it's so funny i
did i had two girls on um on my channel
a couple of weeks ago and my producer
who's on i'm not gonna i'm gonna say
which girl it was obviously she might
just watch this um but one of the girls
after the session he like after she left
he's just like
boy she just taught and talked
i was like yeah it was meant to be a
conversation but it ended up just being
a monologue to be honest
um but i know i think i think a lot of
people i think we can all get like that
over something we're passionate about
do you know what i mean when when when
you talk about something that you're
very passionate about people
can get carried away with it yeah but i
think i think guys communicate
differently from women yeah i just think
we communicate differently they were
very direct like people were saying
we're on yeah and we're on this show
this is quite civilized no one's
screaming over one another
he's in
actually i think it i think it was um
it should have been like this when you
were younger if you've got a fat guy in
your group you're a group of guys you're
a fat guy shut
and obviously he ain't taking no offense
no offense to it like that but yeah
girls are not available it will say
something about you yeah exactly exactly
i'm like yeah shut up whatever hey your
toe looks like one two whatever and then
you
the girls
i think is the complete opposite in
terms of oh yeah okay you're not fat
isn't it oh i imagine the person is fat
oh you're beautiful like like bro they
lie to each other
it's not like i lie to people but
who am i to comment on the way you look
it's more like i just keep my opinions
to my damn
not about not about it
i know it's going to cause
something amongst women yeah but it
depends how you say it what intent you
have when you say it well when i okay
because i was a college athlete so i did
like basketball volleyball and i rent
track and then when i finished it
my eating habits let me tell you they
caught up to me like like real quick
because i wasn't working out like four
hours a day right yeah and i gained a
lot of weight and i wouldn't want anyone
to comment on it like i ended up losing
it once i figured out you know how to
eat less
like i don't know it's like
would it help me if someone tells me i
already knew you know
and maybe it's because you know if we're
being honest as well there's there's
more of a
pressure on women on their appearance i
feel like
so maybe that's why it's kind of like
we're valued more for it yeah yeah which
is a double-edged sword i feel
it can be a double-edged sword because i
feel like now
i think now like
women
are judging
more so other women
you know i mean you think they're
judging other women more yeah i think
women are like
judging other women a lot but not saying
it so
i said like a woman
can walk into this room
and if there's like three if there were
like three females around this table if
a woman walks in
they're thinking who's this [ __ ]
they're thinking like because they're
eyeing her up they're looking at their
competition and especially if there's a
guy in the room yes no i mean like if
there's a guy in the room they're
thinking
what's got her shoes they're looking at
her shoes looking at her hair yeah her
makeup the way you know they're looking
at all of that whereas
i said a guy
if there's if we're around
guy generally yeah yeah because there
are guys that you know do the same but
generally if we're around our guys and
the woman walks in
you've seen this too
actually i'm saying like
actually i was thinking about how you
three didn't know each other and you
guys
like kind of talk like your friends even
though you don't know each other
like it would not be the same if it was
three girls i don't think no
not that didn't know we should like that
didn't know each other yeah that's